Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
2019:
sono passati poco più di dieci anni
da quando i social network
sono arrivati nella nostra società,
e sono diventati parte
della nostra quotidianità.
Dieci anni in cui è cambiato
praticamente tutto.
Quando parliamo di Internet, oggi,
ci chiediamo spesso se la rete
ci stia rendendo più odiatori,
più isolati, più disinformati,
più polarizzati.
Ogni giorno, le notizie che leggiamo
ci raccontano di un mondo
in cui sui social si litiga:
le persone non sono più capaci
di parlarsi senza insultarsi.
E così, noi non capiamo bene
che cosa sta succedendo.
Ma è davvero così?
Ci chiediamo spesso, appunto,
se Internet ci stia rendendo più odiatori:
però forse dovremmo cominciare a cambiare
i focus delle domande,
per capire davvero che cosa
sta succedendo con le piattaforme.
E se davvero le piattaforme,
che erano state create per unirci,
oggi siano responsabili
di una profonda frammentazione sociale.
Come facciamo a capirne i motivi?
Vi voglio lanciare una provocazione:
se invece di chiederci
se i social ci stanno rendendo
solo più odiatori o più disinformati,
cominciassimo a chiederci
se ci stanno rendendo più diseguali?
Cambiando questa prospettiva,
e parlando di disuguaglianza,
forse appunto troveremmo
delle risposte nuove.
Parlare di disuguaglianza,
quando parliamo di Internet,
vuol dire prima di tutto
parlare non solo di odio online
e non solo di disinformazione,
ma parlare di una cosa di cui sentiamo
molto poco parlare, ovvero i dati.
I dati che sono il nucleo,
della società digitale.
Ecco: i dati sono responsabili,
in qualche modo,
del funzionamento della nostra società.
E quando parliamo di dati
e di disuguaglianza,
questo ci serve per chiederci
chi possiede questi dati,
e soprattutto con quali obiettivi.
Una delle prime cose
a cui dobbiamo pensare,
quando parliamo di dati,
è quindi appunto chi li possiede;
e cercare di sfatare
dei miti, anche, sui dati.
A noi viene spontaneo pensare che i dati
siano rappresentativi delle persone,
e fin da quando siamo piccoli ci insegnano
che la matematica non è un'opinione.
E quindi, automaticamente,
ci viene da pensare
che ciò che poi fa funzionare
questi dati, e li aggrega,
ovvero gli algoritmi,
che sono quello che dà il funzionamento
a tutte le applicazioni che usiamo,
a tutte le piattaforme che usiamo,
siano qualcosa di neutrale.
Ma non è così: la tecnologia
non è neutrale,
e questa è una cosa
che dobbiamo tenere davvero a mente.
Perché la tecnologia è un prodotto umano:
dietro ad ogni algoritmo,
dietro ogni applicazione,
dietro ogni piattaforma
c'è un essere umano,
con una propria visione del mondo,
con delle proprie idee
e con dei propri obiettivi.
Ed è proprio questo
il primo passo per cominciare
ad adottare un pensiero critico
verso tutte le piattaforme
che utilizziamo.
Alzi la mano chi non ha mai
sentito la frase:
"Se il servizio è gratis,
il prodotto sei tu".
È infatti piuttosto risaputo
che le piattaforme della Silicon Valley
sono dei grossi monopoli privati
che possiedono i nostri dati
e possiedono gli strumenti
per analizzarli.
E fanno questo a fine di lucro,
per creare delle pubblicità
sempre più personalizzate.
Ormai, le piattaforme sono parte
dell'infrastruttura sociale:
noi le usiamo per qualsiasi cosa,
da prenotare una macchina o un ristorante,
a tenere sotto controllo la nostra salute,
trovare un partner;
però facciamo ancora fatica a capire
come questi algoritmi funzionino;
e soprattutto, poi,
questi dati dove vadano,
con chi vengano condivisi.
Quando parlo di queste cose -
e lo faccio spesso,
infatti ormai i miei amici mi odiano -
una delle cose che mi viene chiesta è:
ma perché me ne dovrei occupare?
Cioè, alla fine a me
le pubblicità personalizzate
non danno fastidio.
Cioè io so cosa comprare,
o comunque della mia privacy
mi importa relativamente,
perché non ho niente da nascondere.
Quando parliamo di privacy,
prima di tutto,
dobbiamo pensare alla privacy
come un diritto umano.
E quindi la privacy
non ha mai avuto a che vedere
con l'idea di non avere
niente da nascondere,
ma piuttosto con la nostra libertà
di ricavarci uno spazio autonomo
e libero da interferenze esterne,
tanto private quanto pubbliche;
ma soprattutto, io credo
che quando parliamo
di privacy oggi, nel 2019,
dobbiamo pensare alla privacy
come un diritto collettivo,
non solo individuale.
Vi faccio un esempio.
Siccome quello che fanno gli algoritmi
non è aggregare tanto i dati di individui
ma piuttosto i dati di gruppi,
quello che succede è che poi gli algoritmi
molto spesso sono in grado, anche,
di conoscere le nostre debolezze -
e utilizzarle, a scopo
di lucro per l'appunto.
Gli algoritmi oggi vengono già utilizzati
per prendere delle decisioni
anche sociali.
Ad esempio,
negli Stati Uniti o in Australia
già si utilizzano gli algoritmi
per decidere se una persona
merita un lavoro,
o se una persona è più o meno
un potenziale criminale,
se merita un mutuo.
Ecco, questi sono degli esempi
che ci insegnano che, come abbiamo detto,
gli algoritmi non sono neutrali.
Perché se l'algoritmo non è neutrale,
quello che farà è utilizzare,
o comunque vedere,
i pregiudizi che ci sono
dentro alla società,
e riprodurli ed espanderli.
Quindi sono diventati molto famosi
casi in cui, per esempio,
come quello che vedete alle mie spalle,
un algoritmo negli Stati Uniti
decideva se una persona
fosse più o meno potenziale criminale,
e risultava discriminante verso i neri;
oppure l'algoritmo di Amazon
che a un certo punto,
tramite Intelligenza Artificiale,
decideva se una persona
fosse più o meno valida
per fare parte dell'azienda,
e risultava discriminante verso le donne.
Perché se la nostra società ci dice
che i neri sono criminali
più probabili dei bianchi,
l'algoritmo dirà la stessa cosa;
e se la società ci dice
che le donne sono meno valide degli uomini
per fare lavori di leadership,
l'algoritmo dirà la stessa cosa.
Ecco perché è un problema collettivo:
perché l'algoritmo riproduce
la cultura dominante.
Ma vi voglio fare un altro esempio:
ci sono casi,
come Cambridge Analytica
o il caso Snowden,
che ci hanno insegnato
che più spesso di quello che pensiamo
le piattaforme utilizzano i nostri dati
e li condividono
non solo con altre aziende,
ma anche con gli Stati, con i governi,
che li utilizzano per conoscere
i nostri movimenti,
le nostre conversazioni - per spiarci.
Questo, ovviamente, è molto problematico.
E vi faccio un esempio:
io sono un'attivista, e per gli attivisti,
che sono coloro che, per definizione,
mettono in discussione il potere
e cercano cambiamento sociale,
la sorveglianza significa controllo.
Questo è già successo in Francia,
non tanto distante da noi,
quando nel 2015,
in seguito alla dichiarazione
dello stato di emergenza
dopo gli attentati terroristici,
il governo francese comincia a seguire
e spiare gli attivisti ecologisti
per evitare che manifestassero.
In questo senso, il diritto alla privacy
è quello che si lega ad altri diritti,
come il diritto a manifestare,
il diritto di organizzazione,
la libertà di espressione.
Sono tutti diritti che hanno
a che vedere con "noi":
non stiamo parlando solo dei miei dati,
stiamo parlando dei nostri dati.
Quindi, quando parliamo
di società digitale
io credo che sia molto importante
che ricominciamo a vederci
come parte di una comunità,
e cominciamo a pensare ai nostri dati
come un bene comune.
Oltre a questo,
dobbiamo cominciare anche
ad adottare uno sguardo critico
in cui cominciamo a chiedere noi,
di decidere che cosa è privato
che cosa è pubblico.
Cominciamo a mettere in discussione
questo nostro ruolo
di cittadini/consumatori,
in cui non ci è dato scegliere -
e sono dei privati, a scegliere -
i termini e le condizioni
della nostra partecipazione sociale,
e della nostra visibilità online
dei contenuti che consumiamo,
che contribuiscono a creare
la nostra visione del mondo.
Dobbiamo, veramente,
riaprire un dibattito completamente nuovo,
e dobbiamo cominciare
a fissare dei limiti etici.
In questo senso,
dobbiamo imparare dal passato,
perché se pensiamo,
per esempio, al petrolio,
il petrolio è stata una risorsa
che ci ha permesso di svilupparci,
come società, in una maniera incredibile.
Però, forse, sarebbe stato meglio
renderci conto prima
che dovevamo regolamentare le aziende
prima di svegliarci
nel mezzo del cambiamento climatico.
Ecco: non possiamo lasciare
che con Internet succeda la stessa cosa.
Dobbiamo fissare dei limiti.
Dopo avervi terrorizzati,
vorrei però provare a lasciarvi
anche un po' di speranza,
raccontando anche
la mia esperienza di attivista.
Io, appunto, di questi temi
mi sono sempre interessata:
ho cominciato studiandoli,
e poi a un certo punto
ho cercato di capire
come li potevo portare
fuori dall'università.
E la prima cosa che ho capito è stata che,
per capire come risolvere
i problemi su Internet,
dobbiamo sempre parlare dall'intersezione
tra società, tecnologia,
politica, economia.
Non possiamo fidarci
di coloro che ci offrono soluzioni
solo tecniche, o solo giuridiche.
Circa un anno fa, sono diventata
il volto di questa campagna
che si chiama "Intimità Violata":
ancora oggi sono emozionata a dirlo,
perché nel giro di pochissimi mesi
da una petizione su change.org
siamo passati ad avere una legge.
E come è stato fatto questo?
È stata creata, prima di tutto,
una rete amplissima di esperti -
che è una cosa che oggi facciamo
sempre meno, consultare gli esperti.
Per Intimità Violata,
e per il "revenge porn" -
la condivisione non consensuale
di materiale intimo -
abbiamo avuto bisogno di consultare
non solo giuristi, non solo politici,
ma anche informatici,
psicologi, sociologi.
Insomma, abbiamo veramente creato
una rete dal basso
per fare in modo di approcciarci
a questi problemi nel modo giusto.
E questo è stato molto importante
perché nel nostro percorso
c'è stato chi proponeva
delle soluzioni alternative alle nostre,
per esempio,
c'era chi proponeva
di vietare il "sexting",
ovvero lo scambio
di video/foto intime tra partner,
andando di fatto a censurare
la libertà di espressione dei cittadini;
oppure c'è chi proponeva
solo soluzioni tecniche,
dicendo: "Implementiamo
il fingerprinting, l'impronta digitale:
creiamo dei grossi archivi on line
in cui tutte le foto
che sono sulle piattaforme
sono schedate insieme,
e in questo modo rimuoveremo
il materiale più rapidamente"
andando a creare di fatto problemi
per la sorveglianza dei cittadini.
Ecco: questo è un esempio per dire
che quando parliamo
di Internet, di problemi,
dobbiamo veramente adottare
uno sguardo sociale e culturale,
cioè renderci conto
che come il revenge porn, per esempio,
non nasce da Internet,
ma nasce da una violenza
che è già presente nella società -
quella contro le donne.
Allo stesso modo,
l'odio online non lo risolveremo
solo parlando di far iscrivere i cittadini
sulle piattaforme con un documento;
o il problema dei monopoli su Internet
non lo risolveremo utilizzando
tecnologie nuove come la blockchain,
perché non esiste la causa e l'effetto
dell'utilizzo di una tecnologia,
dobbiamo pensare in una maniera
completamente nuova.
Per fare questo, ci sono
due cose che possiamo fare.
La prima è educarci.
Dobbiamo conoscere i nostri diritti,
per poterli difendere.
Dobbiamo parlare del problema
dell'accentramento di poteri su Internet
con i monopoli;
dobbiamo parlare di come
funzionano le piattaforme;
dobbiamo cominciare a chiedere noi,
che cosa vogliamo.
E dobbiamo parlare di cos'è privato
e di cos'è pubblico.
L'altra cosa è unirsi, fare attivismo.
A me piace molto, in questo caso,
citare Greta Thumberg,
che dice "Activism Works":
l'attivismo funziona.
Ed è davvero così!
Forse noi, ancora dentro
al nostro sguardo un po' individualista
che ci siamo abituati ad adottare,
ci siamo dimenticati della potenza
di tante persone che si mettono insieme
per portare avanti qualcosa.
Però la verità è che,
se vogliamo cambiamento sociale,
dobbiamo ricominciare a guardarci.
Perché qui, quando parliamo
di diritti digitali,
parliamo del futuro
della nostra democrazia.
Parliamo del fatto che dobbiamo chiederci
come fare a risolvere
l'immensa forbice sociale
che le piattaforme stanno creando,
e come risolvere veramente l'odio online.
Questo, appunto,
sarà un processo molto lungo,
però credo che sarà l'unica cosa
che possiamo davvero fare.
Anche perché dobbiamo parlare
di quello che Internet può fare,
non solo dei problemi che causa.
Nel senso che Internet,
non solo nel mio caso ma nel mondo,
è stato responsabile
dell'espansione dei movimenti sociali,
da #metoo a #FridayForFuture.
È diventato uno strumento
per fare in modo che le persone
si potessero unire sulla rete,
e allo stesso tempo
può creare anche degli spazi sicuri
per le persone per parlarsi,
per le comunità discriminate.
Quindi, crediamoci nel fatto
che Internet ci possa aiutare:
però, prima, chiediamoci
dove stiamo andando.
Siamo in un momento cruciale della Storia,
e dobbiamo veramente,
veramente cominciare a lavorare insieme.
Una delle cose che ho imparato quest'anno
è che le persone ti diranno sempre
che non cambia mai niente,
che non possiamo fare niente,
che le cose sono così.
Però, quello che io oggi
spero di potervi lasciare
è che non è vero.
Non è vero perché io ho cominciato
da zero, e oggi sono qui.
Ed è stato solo perché ci ho creduto.
Quindi, crediamo nei nostri diritti,
crediamo nelle nostre libertà
e crediamo nel cambiamento.
Grazie.
(Applausi)